with this launch south korea has joined
an exclusive international club
one of only a handful of nations able to
put satellites into orbit commercially
the three-stage rocket called nuri
meaning world was carrying a one and a
half ton test satellite up to 700
kilometers above the surface of the
earth
a first attempt last october failed when
the rocket's third stage malfunctioned
that added to the anticipation of this
launch bringing large crowds to the
beaches facing south korea's naru space
center
they weren't disappointed
the engineers believe they've fixed the
problems and that this time nuri will
become the first homegrown south korean
rocket to put a satellite in orbit
i came here for the first launch and it
was a disappointment when it failed so
this time i'm hoping for success
at the moment of ignition i said wow
then the roar of the rocket made me so
proud
i feel like we've joined the ranks of
truly advanced countries
70 minutes after the launch the
country's science minister was able to
claim success
fellow koreans the sky of the korean
universe has been open wide
now the government plans to increase the
technical reliability and stability of
the nuri rocket through four more
launches by 2027.
this launch has further accelerated the
pace of rocket development on the korean
peninsula north korea says it launched
its first satellites years ago but many
analysts believe that was just a cover
for the development of its long-range
ballistic missiles rob mcbride al
jazeera gohung south korea